OK, so here's a weird thing to happen at your temp job. A chunk of the country decides that you, personally, are trying to steal the election from the president of the United States. This actually happened to a guy. He's in this video that's been circulating online, retweeted by Eric Trump and Donald Trump Jr., viewed over 5 million times, of him.
好吧，这可是你做临时工时遇到的怪事。全国有一部分人认定，你个人正在试图从美国总统手中窃取选举成果。这事真的发生在一个人身上。网上流传着一段他的视频，小唐纳德·特朗普和埃里克·特朗普都转发了，观看量超过500万次。
He's this worker in the Georgia vote counting operation. In the video, you see him at a desk in short sleeves, people doing their jobs all around him. He picks up one piece of paper after another, puts them in a stack. And then, something happens. He flinches and he slams down a piece of paper kind of angrily-- or that's how it looks in the video. The sound on the video is somebody narrating who's not identified.
他是在佐治亚州计票工作中负责的一名员工。视频里，你看到他穿着短袖坐在桌前，周围的人都在忙着自己的工作。他一张接一张地拿起纸，把它们叠成一摞。然后，事情发生了。他瑟缩了一下，有些恼怒地把一张纸拍在桌上——或者在视频里看起来是这样。视频里的声音是一个身份不明的人在解说。
This dude has a fit about something, flips off a ballot, and then crumples it up.
这家伙因为什么事发了火，对一张选票竖了中指，然后把它揉成一团。
That's more or less true. The guy gives a finger to something and then does crumple up some piece of paper and then drops it to the side. The narrator and so many commenters online for the video assume this is a Trump ballot. And this fits the mold of all the things the president has been saying about the election being stolen.
这基本属实。那个人对着什么东西竖了中指，然后确实揉皱了一张纸，随手扔到了一边。视频的解说员和网上许多评论者都认为这是一张投给特朗普的选票。这正好符合总统一直在说的关于选举被窃取的所有论调。
If that's not voter fraud, I don't know what is.
如果这都不叫选民舞弊，我不知道什么才叫。
Fortunately for us at our program, this incident happened in Fulton County in Atlanta, where WABE reporter Johnny Kauffman has been embedded in the elections operation for months. He was able to track down the guy in the video.
对我们节目组来说幸运的是，这起事件发生在亚特兰大的富尔顿县，WABE电台记者约翰尼·考夫曼在那里深入选举一线工作了几个月。他成功找到了视频中的那个人。
His name is Lawrence Sloane. He's one of the dozens of people who were hired during the busy time around elections to help out.
他叫劳伦斯·斯隆。他是选举期间为帮忙而雇佣的数十人之一。
Has he done it before?
他以前做过这个吗？
No, this is his first time working in the election.
没有，这是他第一次参加选举工作。
Yeah, I mean, as soon as they called me about the opportunity, I was like, oh, sweet. I get paid. I get to help democracy. That's the most American thing. That's going to be awesome, you know?
是的，我是说，他们一打电话告诉我这个机会，我就想，哦，太好了。有工资拿。我还能帮助民主。这是最美国的事了。这肯定很棒，你知道吧？
Lawrence explained to me that the machine he's sitting at in the video, it's an envelope opener. Or the election workers, they call it a cutter. So Fulton County had about 150,000 mail-in ballots come in, so they were running nonstop. And Lawrence is one of the fastest people on the machines. He can tell, just by the sound, whether they're working correctly or not.
劳伦斯向我解释说，视频里他坐的那台机器是拆信机。或者说选举工作人员称之为裁切机。富尔顿县收到了大约15万张邮寄选票，所以机器一直在不停地运转。劳伦斯是操作这些机器最快的人之一。光听声音，他就能判断机器是否工作正常。
I know when there's going to be an error. You hear [CLICKING]. That's the letter landing in the dropping. [CLICKING] That's where it cuts along the side. [CLICKING] If you don't hear [CLICKING], it didn't work. You didn't hear [CLICKING] sink, you got no cut on both sides, all right?
我知道什么时候会出故障。你听到[咔哒声]。那是信件落入收集器里。[咔哒声]那是机器在侧面切割的声音。[咔哒声]如果你没听到[咔哒声]，那就是没成功。你没听到[咔哒声]沉下去，说明两边都没切开，明白吗？
Lawrence told me that people put all kinds of stuff in the envelopes, like weird stuff that they're not supposed to put in there.
劳伦斯告诉我，人们会在信封里塞各种东西，比如一些不该放进去的奇怪物品。
Like what?
比如什么？
Oh, like mean notes about Trump. Someone sent in a check.
哦，比如写给特朗普的刻薄纸条。有人寄来了一张支票。
Oh, is this like a mistake? They put it in the wrong envelope?
哦，这是弄错了吗？他们把支票装错了信封？
Yeah, just a mistake.
是的，只是个错误。
Poems. People write poems, and they put them in there. Prayers.
诗。人们写诗，然后把它们放进去。还有祈祷文。
What kind of poems?
什么样的诗？
Just, like, I don't-- bro, just not good ones.
就是那种，我不知道……兄弟，写得真不怎么样。
So did you watch the video with him?
那么你和他一起看这段视频了吗？
Oh, yeah. He was very happy and excited to explain what actually happened in the video.
哦，看了。他非常乐意且兴奋地解释视频里到底发生了什么。
OK, so the machine-- yeah, you see them working the workflow. That's me separating. Boom, separate, take that one up. Boom, separate. Now it's running pretty good there. Oh, bam! It tries to eat my hand.
好吧，机器……你看他们操作流程。那是我在分拣。砰，分开，把那张拿起来。砰，分开。现在它运行得挺好的。哦，该死！它想吃掉我的手。
Wait, what's happening there?
等等，那儿发生了什么？
Yeah, so what's happening is the machine didn't cut the envelope quite right. And so Lawrence reached in his hand to save the ballot.
是的，发生的情况是机器没把信封切好。所以劳伦斯伸手去抢救那张选票。
When it doesn't cut properly, it starts tearing them-- it starts tearing the ballots out. So it starts tearing the envelope. And then if it stays in there, it will tear the ballot apart. And we can't have it eat your ballot. That's why you see me throw those things.
如果切不准，它就开始撕裂……它开始撕扯选票。它开始撕信封。如果选票留在里面，它就会把选票撕烂。我们不能让它把选票吃了。这就是你看到我把那些东西扔掉的原因。
So that's what the guy saw in the video. When Lawrence flinched, it wasn't him being upset about a Trump vote. It was the machine tweaked him when he was trying to reach into it and save a ballot. So then he flipped off the machine. He's not flipping off the ballot. He's flipping off the machine--
所以视频里那人看到的就是这个。当劳伦斯瑟缩时，并不是因为他对投给特朗普的票感到不满。是因为当他试图伸手进去抢救选票时，机器夹到了他。所以他才对着机器竖了中指。他不是对着选票竖中指。他是对着机器竖中指……
Oh.
哦。
--because it had been giving him problems for hours.
……因为它已经让他折腾好几个小时了。
Yeah, I flip off the machine. I'm like, you used to be cool, man. We used to do good work. Now I'm tired, too. Everybody in here is tired, but you need to quit with this shit, all right? You're the only person in here eating fingers. [LAUGHS]
是的，我对着机器竖中指。我想的是，你以前挺酷的啊，伙计。我们以前合作得很好。现在我也累了。这里每个人都累了，但你得停止这破事，好吗？你是这儿唯一一个吃手指的家伙。[笑声]
So then the last thing in the video is Lawrence throwing aside this piece of paper. And Lawrence told me that that is not a ballot. It's one of these things that people put in the envelopes that is not supposed to be in the envelope.
所以视频里最后那个动作是劳伦斯扔掉了那张纸。劳伦斯告诉我，那不是选票。那是人们放进信封里、本不该出现在那里的东西。
Oh.
哦。
In this case, it was the instructions actually for how to fill out the ballot. When Lawrence was talking about this, he couldn't help himself from giving a little public service announcement.
这次是关于如何填写选票的说明书。当劳伦斯谈到这点时，他忍不住发表了一段简短的公共服务公告。
Stop putting the instructions in. I know it's too late now. For future reference, don't include the instructions in your voting thing. It just makes more work for us. And It's weird. So just stop it.
别把说明书放进去了。我知道现在说太晚了。但以后请注意，投票时不要把说明书放进去。这只会给我们增加更多工作。而且这很奇怪。所以，别再这么做了。
OK, so the video was shot on Wednesday, the day after the election. It took off online the next morning. That's when Lawrence learned that lots of his fellow Americans thought that he was rigging the election. Again, here's Johnny Kaufman.
好了，这段视频拍摄于周三，也就是选举后的第二天。第二天早上它就在网上火了。那时劳伦斯才知道，许多美国同胞认为他在操纵选举。再说一次，这是约翰尼·考夫曼。
Someone sent it to him on Instagram. And he looked at it, and he's like, oh, this is going to be a problem. In the comments, people were saying, like, he should be identified and arrested, that he was mentally ill and homeless, like nasty, racist stuff.
有人在Instagram上发给他。他看了之后想，哦，这下麻烦了。评论区里，有人说应该人肉他并逮捕他，说他有精神病，是流浪汉，全是那种恶毒的种族歧视言论。
Lawrence, we should say, is Black. And was he at work when he learns this?
我们应该说明，劳伦斯是黑人。他当时在上班吗？
Yeah, he's in the middle of a 22-hour shift. So then he takes a break. He goes outside to get away from the TV cameras and reporters in the room. And at that point, he sees Trump supporters protesting.
是的，他当时正在值一个22小时的班。然后他休息了一会儿。他走到外面，为了躲开室内的摄像机和记者。就在那时，他看到了特朗普的支持者在抗议。
I didn't know when the protest was about. Even if it's not about me, I'm standing outside, and they know what I look like. You know what I'm saying? And if any of them had seen this, every second that this goes by, more people are going to see this. Me just being here is automatically just not the best.
我不知道抗议是关于什么的。即使不是针对我，我站在外面，他们知道我长什么样。你知道我的意思吗？如果他们中有人看过这个视频，每过一秒，就会有更多人看到。仅仅因为我在这里，处境就不太妙。
And how are you feeling in that moment?
那你当时感觉怎么样？
Scared. It wasn't like a-- I'm shook. It's like, oh. Because fear is a real emotion. You're like, oh. And it isn't always like, heartbeat, boom boom boom. It's like, I am in danger. I should probably get the hell on.
害怕。那种感觉不是……我吓坏了。就是那种，哦。因为恐惧是一种真实的感受。你会想，哦。这并不总是那种心跳加速、砰砰砰的感觉。而是一种，我有危险。我最好赶紧离开。
So at the end of day, he just sneaks away, past the protest?
所以在一天结束时，他是溜走的，躲开了抗议人群？
Yeah, he actually ran away. He said he ran to get away from the protesters. And then he hit out with some friends. He cut his beard off and dyed his hair so people wouldn't recognize him.
是的，他实际上是逃走的。他说他跑着躲开了抗议者。然后他去朋友那里躲藏。他刮掉了胡子，染了头发，这样人们就认不出他了。
Oh, wow.
哦，天哪。
That wasn't too big of a deal in the end because he said he really likes his new look. But he didn't feel safe going home for three nights.
最终这也没什么大不了的，因为他说他其实挺喜欢自己的新造型。但有三个晚上他觉得回家不安全。
There are so many of these stories of voter fraud on the internet right now. I talked to this woman who founded a company that tracks disinformation on the internet, the Alethea Group. The woman's name is Lisa Kaplan. And she told me that Election Day was way calmer than they expected for disinformation. A limited number of false stories, most of them about Pennsylvania. But starting the next day, things sped up. And they really exploded once the president started spreading these stories in earnest.
现在互联网上有太多关于选民舞弊的故事了。我采访了一位创办了一家追踪网络虚假信息公司的女性，Alethea集团的丽莎·卡普兰。她告诉我，选举日比他们预期的要平静得多。虚假故事数量有限，大多是关于宾夕法尼亚州的。但从第二天开始，情况加速了。一旦总统开始认真散布这些故事，事情就真正爆发了。
Disinformation is continuing to grow exponentially. And the way it is now, it's much more diffuse. So it's not just on 8Kun or 4chan anymore. These are narratives that are being talked about on Facebook, on Twitter, on Instagram.
虚假信息正呈指数级增长。而且现在的情况是，它更加分散了。所以它不再只存在于8Kun或4chan上了。这些叙事正在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上被广泛讨论。
How often are the stories true of voter fraud?
关于选民舞弊的故事有多少是真的？
We have not found any. None of the narratives that we are tracking are backed up by facts.
我们没有发现任何一起。我们追踪的叙事中没有一个是有事实支撑的。
Lots of people now believe these stories of voter fraud. A survey by Politico in the Morning Consult found that 70% of Republicans think this year's election was not free and fair. And over half of Republicans think there was widespread voter fraud with mail-in ballots.
现在很多人相信这些选民舞弊的故事。Morning Consult进行的一项民调显示，70%的共和党人认为今年的选举不自由、不公平。超过半数的共和党人认为邮寄选票存在大规模的选民舞弊。
Driving through Aberdeen, Maryland the weekend after the election, I saw a few dozen Trump supporters gathering to do an impromptu car caravan supporting the president. Just the day before that, news organizations had called the election for Joe Biden. When I talked to this chatty, friendly woman named Kim Muhlenfeld and her friend and this kid, they, like most of this crowd, didn't buy it.
选举后的那个周末，当我驱车穿过马里兰州的阿伯丁时，我看到几十名特朗普支持者聚集在一起，进行了一场自发的车队游行来支持总统。就在前一天，新闻机构宣布乔·拜登赢得了选举。当我与一位名叫金·穆伦费尔德的健谈、友善的女士以及她的朋友和孩子交谈时，他们和大多数群众一样，并不相信这一点。
It was obviously the vote was stolen. And we can't let the media say who our president is going be. We just can't. I mean--
很明显选票被窃取了。我们不能让媒体来决定谁是我们的总统。我们就是不能。我的意思是……
Where'd you hear--
你是从哪里听到的……
--they talk about a free and fair election at this point, not even so much Trump. But I have a video of CNN before the ribbon at the bottom catches up--
……他们现在谈论什么自由公平的选举，甚至都不太提特朗普了。但我有一段CNN的视频，在底部的条幅出来之前……
Kim pointed me to a bunch of videos she says proves there's fraud. From her perspective, there are so many examples to choose from-- votes turning up unexplained in the middle of the night.
金给我指了一堆她认为能证明存在舞弊的视频。从她的角度来看，有太多例子可以选择——深夜里无法解释地突然出现的选票。
4:00 AM, no votes for Trump at all, just 132,000 Biden votes, that's it, at 4:00 AM.
凌晨4点，完全没有投给特朗普的票，只有13.2万张投给拜登的，就是这样，在凌晨4点。
Kim's slightly misremembering those numbers, but what she's talking about is a story that the Alethea Group says is one of the most circulated bits of disinformation about this election, widely shared on right-wing bulletin boards and websites and one of the many stories that the president has retweeted.
金对那些数字有些记错了，但她在谈论的是一个故事，Alethea集团称这是关于此次选举流传最广的虚假信息之一，在右翼论坛和网站上被广泛分享，也是总统转发的众多故事之一。
It was on Fox News. It was a tweet with side by side maps of Michigan and vote counts, showing that early in the morning after Election Day, Michigan updated its election totals, added 138,000 votes to the vote count, and all the new votes, all of them, went to Joe Biden, none to Donald Trump, which does sound very suspicious.
福克斯新闻上也播了。那是一条推文，附带密歇根州的并排地图和投票统计，显示选举日后的早晨，密歇根州更新了选举总数，增加了13.8万张选票，所有新增加的选票，全都是投给乔·拜登的，没有一张给唐纳德·特朗普的，这听起来确实非常可疑。
But it's not what it seems. The person who made this happen was a Republican, the Republican official responsible for running elections in a Republican county in Michigan-- this woman.
但事实并非如此。造成这一结果的人是一名共和党人，也就是负责管理密歇根州一个共和党县选举的官员……这位女士。
Caroline Wilson, Shiawasee County clerk.
卡罗琳·威尔逊，希亚瓦西县书记员。
Feel free not to answer this question because I think it's a private thing, but did you vote for the president?
如果你不想回答这个问题可以不回答，因为我觉得这是私事，但你投给了总统吗？
I did.
我投了。
Both times?
两次都投了？
Yes. I stand by the values that the Republican Party holds. And that's what I support.
是的。我坚持共和党持有的价值观。那也是我所支持的。
Here's what happened with those 138,000 votes, according to Caroline. Morning after the election, 4:45, she and the elections clerk, Abby Bowen, were in her office, just the two of them, sending in election results to the state, using the computer that's set up with all the security measures on it. With each race--
根据卡罗琳的说法，那13.8万张选票发生的情况如下。选举后的早晨4点45分，她和选举书记员艾比·鲍恩在她的办公室里，只有她们两个人，正在使用安装了所有安全措施的计算机将选举结果发送给州里。对于每一场竞选……
Abby reads the number to me. I type the number, repeating the number.
艾比给我读数字。我输入数字，重复那个数字。
But Caroline says, in filling out this form online, before she would actually type anything into a box, the number that was sitting there in the box as a place holder was zero. And usually she'll put the cursor in the box, and her new number would replace the zero. But as she was typing in Biden's number, the cursor landed in the box, but it didn't nuke the zero that was there.
但卡罗琳说，在网上填写这份表格时，在她真正输入任何东西进方框之前，方框里本来就有一个占位符数字“零”。通常她会把光标放在方框里，她输入的新数字会取代那个零。但当她在输入拜登的票数时，光标落在了方框里，但它没有覆盖掉原本在那里的零。
I must have had the cursor to the left of the zero. I didn't even see it. So I typed in 15, 371.
我肯定把光标放在零的左边了。我甚至没看见。所以我输入了15371。
That is 15,371 votes, Joe Biden's total for the county. But because the zero was there at the end of the number, it wasn't 15,000 and change. The number was 150,000 and change.
那是15371张选票，是乔·拜登在该县的总得票数。但因为最后有一个零，它就不是1万5千多张了。那个数字变成了15万多张。
We moved down to Donald Trump, his number. I would read the number back. I would go to the next person. We hit Submit, and we pretty much go home. It's been a long couple of days.
我们往下进行到唐纳德·特朗普的票数。我会读回那个数字。我会进行到下一个人。我们点击“提交”，然后我们就基本回家了。过去几天真是漫长。
It does not take long for somebody from the Bureau of Elections to notice this error. Caroline and Abby both get calls in 20 minutes. Caroline's already home. She lives seven minutes from her office. They get rid of 153,000 that Caroline typed in, replace it with 15,300.
没过多久，选举局的人就注意到了这个错误。卡罗琳和艾比在20分钟内都接到了电话。卡罗琳已经在家里了。她离办公室只有7分钟路程。他们删除了卡罗琳输入的那15.3万，用15300取代了它。
The difference between those two numbers is the mysterious 138,000 votes, which-- this part is interesting-- didn't actually appear for Biden in the vote count. They disappeared for Biden to make it look like they mysteriously appeared. Our best guess is somebody must have intentionally switched the before and after pictures of the map with the vote totals.
这两个数字之间的差额就是那神秘的13.8万张选票，而且——这部分很有意思——它们并没有真正出现在拜登的计票结果中。它们消失了，使得看起来像是神秘地出现了一样。我们最好的猜测是有人故意切换了投票统计地图的前后对比图。
But it was corrected very quickly. So we just moved on. And lo and behold, our phone is blowing up and emails are blowing up. And even my family, they didn't know it was me, but they were joking about all these votes in Shiawasee County. Yeah, I might know a thing or two about that, but it was clearly a typo. We don't even have that many people in our county.
但它很快就被纠正了。所以我们就继续工作了。结果没想到，我们的电话被打爆了，邮件也被塞爆了。甚至我的家人，他们不知道是我干的，但他们开玩笑说希亚瓦西县出现了这么多选票。是的，我可能知道那一两件事，但那显然是一个输入错误。我们县甚至都没有那么多人。
So after I talked to Caroline, I found that woman that I met at the rally, Kim, who had been so convinced that 130-some thousand votes had appeared in middle of the night for Biden. I was curious to find out if she would believe Caroline's story. And I played her clips from my recording of Caroline, explaining point by point how it happened. And then they fixed it and made it the right numbers.
在和卡罗琳交谈后，我找到了我在集会上遇到的那位女士金，她一直确信有13万多张选票在深夜里为拜登出现。我很好奇她是否会相信卡罗琳的故事。我给她播放了我录音中卡罗琳的片段，逐点解释了事情是如何发生的。然后他们修复了它，把它改回了正确的数字。
Right, but this has happened all over the country. And the video I sent you yesterday, you can see all the ways that this Dominion software, as well as others, can be-- what happens is, in that--
没错，但这在全国各地都发生过。我昨天发给你的视频里，你可以看到Dominion软件以及其他软件的所有方式……可以被……发生的情况是，在那个……
Dominion is another one of those stories tweeted by the president and circulating on the internet. It's one of a bunch of stories about rigged software giving votes to Joe Biden. It has been dis-proven. Google Dominion if you're curious.
Dominion是总统转发并在互联网上传播的另一个故事。它是关于操纵软件将选票投给乔·拜登的众多故事之一。它已经被辟谣了。如果你好奇，可以去谷歌搜索Dominion。
But do you understand in this case, it's not Dominion software or the other software. It's just her typing in the number wrong.
但你明白吗，在这个案例中，不是Dominion软件或其他软件的问题。这只是她把数字输错了。
Right, sure. Yeah, I mean, that's plausible. But she said she must have, so she doesn't know for sure, for one. But if it was just an isolated case, that would be one thing. But it's just too much. And maybe she really didn't make an error. Maybe they just changed it, and they caught the change like they caught the 6,000 in another county. So you don't really know what's happening. And it's just--
对，当然。是的，我的意思是，这确实有可能。但她说她肯定是弄错了，所以她也不确定，这是其一。但如果只是个例，那是一回事。但事实太多了。也许她真的没有犯错。也许他们只是改了数字，然后他们像在另一个县抓到那6000张票一样抓到了这次改动。所以你真的不知道发生了什么。而且这只是……
And I just want to be sure.
我只是想确认一下。
It's just terrible.
这真是太可怕了。
I just want to be sure I'm clear. Kim, you're saying that she thinks that she did it as a typographical error, but you think maybe this--
我只是想确保我说清楚了。金，你是说她认为自己犯了一个输入错误，但你认为也许这是……
I think when they send off the results, that's when the percentages are changed.
我认为当他们发送结果时，那就是百分比被更改的时候。
Mm-hmm. But you're saying it might not even be true that she made a typographical error.
嗯。但你是说，即使她说她犯了一个输入错误，也可能不是真的？
Right, I mean, there's just so many anomalies. And there's no way that Joe Biden got more votes than Donald Trump. No way possible.
对，我的意思是，有太多异常情况了。乔·拜登不可能比唐纳德·特朗普获得更多的票。绝不可能。
Kim said a few times that Caroline seems like a credible and honest person, but it's the sheer volume of other examples that's convincing to her that they really could be foul play. And even if this one example in this one Michigan county was caught, it doesn't change anything for her because she feels like she's seen so many other examples.
金曾几次说卡罗琳看起来像个可信且诚实的人，但其他大量例子让她确信这确实可能存在猫腻。即使密歇根州这个县的例子被抓住了，对她来说也改变不了什么，因为她觉得她已经看到了太多其他例子。
I asked Caroline Wilson, the Shiawasee County clerk, what she thinks of all the Republicans who don't believe the truth of what happened in her county.
我问希亚瓦西县书记员卡罗琳·威尔逊，她怎么看待那些不相信她县里所发生之真相的共和党人。
Shame on them. Shame on them. That attitude jeopardizes everything that we are supposed to stand for. I take an oath to uphold the Constitution of the United States, this state, and my county. And my job responsibilities are not partisan.
为他们感到羞耻。真为他们感到羞耻。那种态度损害了我们应该代表的一切。我宣誓要维护美国宪法，维护本州，维护本县。我的工作职责无关党派。
Fact is, there's no convincing people-- usually. Something I read this year that really shaped how I've seen this whole election is Ezra Klein's book Why We're Polarized. He has this big section where he runs through all these studies that demonstrate how, when we encounter facts that don't fit into our worldview, that contradict what we believe, the normal thing, the thing that we all do most of the time is that we disregard those facts or explain them away.
事实是，通常情况下，人们是说服不了的。今年我读到的一本书真正塑造了我看待这场选举的方式，那就是埃兹拉·克莱恩的《为什么我们两极分化》。他有一大章内容，详细列举了所有这些研究，证明当我们遇到不符合我们世界观、与我们信念相悖的事实时，我们所有人大多数时候做的正常反应，就是无视这些事实或对其进行合理解释。
Today on our program, in this moment when the president is not backing down from his unproven claim that the election was stolen from him, this moment when I know that when I call the president's tweets disinformation, there are a lot of you out there like him who think that I am part of the problem and not looking at the truth, we thought it might be nice to hear a few of the rare examples of people actually changing their minds. It doesn't happen often, God knows. But let's enjoy a few cases where it does and look at why it does in those special cases. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，在这个总统对他窃取了选举成果的未经证实的说法不松口的时刻，在这个我知道当我称总统的推文为虚假信息时，你们当中有很多人像他一样认为我是问题的一部分、而不是在看真相的时刻，我们想，也许听听一些罕见的、人们真正改变主意的例子会很好。这种情况不常发生，天知道。但让我们享受几个确实发生这种情况的案例，并看看为什么在那些特殊情况下会发生。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, The Signs, They Are A-Changing. So Lizzie Johnson's grandpa recently surprised everybody in his life by changing his mind about something.
第一幕，迹象表明，他们正在改变。莉齐·约翰逊的爷爷最近通过改变对某件事的看法，让身边的每个人都感到惊讶。
A month ago, I woke up to my cell phone pinging with text alerts. My family group chat was blowing up over a picture-- a huge Biden-Harris sign staked in my grandpa's field. He's 91 and a lifelong Republican. And until this sign, no one in my family knew he'd switched allegiances. It was shocking. The man doesn't change his mind about anything. But this year, he'd sent in his mail-in ballot for Biden. And for the first time in his life, he'd also voted a straight Democratic ticket. What had made him change his mind after so long?
一个月前，我醒来时手机响个不停，全都是短信提醒。我的家庭群聊因为一张照片而炸开了锅——一张巨大的拜登-哈里斯竞选牌插在我爷爷的田地里。他91岁了，是个终身共和党人。在出现这块牌子之前，我家里没人知道他已经改换了门庭。这太令人震惊了。这个男人对任何事都不会改变主意。但今年，他寄出了他的邮寄选票给拜登。而且他一生中第一次投了民主党的全票。到底是什么让他坚持了这么久之后改变了主意？
[DIAL TONE]
[拨号音]
So I think we need to give grandpa just a couple more minutes.
我想我们需要再给爷爷几分钟。
That's my mom Rose. I'd sent over my list of questions to him to look at before we talked because he's hard of hearing.
那是我的母亲罗斯。我之前把我的问题清单发给他看了，因为他听力不太好。
He wrote out all the answers, and I think he's back there re-copying them right now.
他写下了所有答案，我想他现在在后面重抄一遍。
I'm not ready.
我还没准备好。
My grandpa's named Louis Rosman. He's pretty blustery and known for his quick temper. He lives by himself on his 500-acre corn and soybean farm in Harlan, Iowa. It's the same farm he grew up on. The area is conservative and rural.
我爷爷叫路易斯·罗斯曼。他脾气暴躁，以急性子闻名。他一个人住在爱荷华州哈伦市他那500英亩的玉米和大豆农场里。那是他从小长大的农场。这个地区保守且偏远。
Hi, grandpa.
嗨，爷爷。
Hi there.
你好。
How are you doing?
你好吗？
Not too good. [LAUGHS] I can't work under pressure.
不太好。[笑声] 我没法在压力下工作。
[LAUGHS] So I heard that you had cut down all the overgrown grass, all the weeds, just so that everyone could see the sign better from the highway, which seems like a little risky. Do your neighbors on either side, do they have Trump signs on their fields?
[笑声] 所以我听说你把所有过长的草和杂草都割了，就是为了让大家能从公路上更好地看清牌子，这看起来有点冒险。你两边的邻居，他们的田里有特朗普的牌子吗？
Oh, yes, big signs. I've probably got a neighbor on each side of me that would tear it down, but I closed the gate up so they can't get in to do it.
哦，是的，大牌子。我的两边可能各有一个邻居会把它拆了，但我把大门关上了，所以他们进不来。
He's really proud of this sign. He got it by calling up the leaders of the Democratic Party in his county. It turned out, one of them is a distant relative.
他真的很为这块牌子感到自豪。他是通过给县里民主党的领导人打电话得到的。结果发现，其中一个是远房亲戚。
I told them they could not find a better display for their sign anywhere than down here on this highway. It's a busy highway.
我告诉他们，他们在这个公路上任何地方都找不到比这儿更好的展示牌子的位置了。这是一条繁忙的公路。
Remember you asked them to bring you the biggest sign?
记得你让他们给你带最大的牌子吗？
Yeah, I wanted a big one. And they only had a single one. I wanted a second one so we could put it back to back, you know, so you could see it both ways on the highway.
是的，我想要一块大的。他们只有一个。我想要第二个，这样我们就可以背靠背放，你知道，这样你在公路上两个方向都能看到。
Highway 44 is a busy two-lane route that runs between Portsmouth and Harlan in western Iowa. There'd been another Biden-Harris sign in town, but a 92-year-old man defaced it. He spray painted it with a big red X. And then, the sign disappeared.
44号公路是连接爱荷华州西部朴次茅斯和哈伦之间的一条繁忙的双车道公路。镇上曾有另一块拜登-哈里斯的牌子，但一个92岁的老人毁坏了它。他用喷漆喷了一个大大的红色X。然后，牌子就不见了。
My grandpa Louis's neighbors are mostly farmers who voted for President Trump in 2016. His trade war with China ate into their profits, but then he bailed them out with subsidies. He's still popular with farmers. Back in 2016, my grandfather voted for him, too.
我爷爷路易斯的邻居大多是2016年投票给特朗普总统的农民。他与中国的贸易战削减了他们的利润，但后来他用补贴救了他们。他在农民中仍然很受欢迎。早在2016年，我爷爷也投票给了他。
Because everybody wanted a change, and I just fell into place with them. I wanted something different.
因为每个人都想要改变，我也随大流了。我想要点不同的东西。
What was it that you wanted to change?
你想要改变的是什么？
I don't know. I have always voted Republican for the president, and that's probably the biggest reason. I didn't know any better.
我不知道。我一直投票给共和党的总统，这可能是最大的原因。我当时什么都不懂。
My grandpa was a Republican by upbringing. His parents were Republican. Like most people, he absorbed his political beliefs by osmosis. Everyone belongs to the same Catholic church in town, St. Michael's. It's right next to where that other sign was defaced. Church was the only place my grandpa used to talk with his neighbors before the pandemic hit. Now his social life is a lot quieter. The farms are spread so far apart that he doesn't really run into people. The only other person he sees is a friend named Paul, who rents land from my grandpa. He's a Trump supporter.
我爷爷从小就是共和党。他的父母是共和党。像大多数人一样，他通过潜移默化吸收了他的政治信仰。镇上每个人都属于同一个天主教堂，圣迈克尔教堂。它就在那块被毁坏的牌子旁边。疫情爆发前，教堂是我爷爷和邻居们交流的唯一地方。现在他的社交生活安静多了。农场相距甚远，他真的碰不到人。他唯一见到的人是一个名叫保罗的朋友，他租了我爷爷的地。他是特朗普的支持者。
Has Paul said anything about your sign?
保罗对你的牌子说过什么吗？
No. He knows it's down here. But Paul naturally would not say anything. Because I can terminate his lease next year.
没有。他知道牌子在这儿。但保罗自然什么都不会说。因为明年我可以终止他的租约。
Oh. [LAUGHS] But do you guys talk about politics?
哦。[笑声] 但你们谈论政治吗？
We don't talk about politics. We talk about engines that don't start and stuff like that.
我们不谈政治。我们谈论发动机启动不了之类的事情。
But how did you find out that Paul was going to vote for Trump?
但你是怎么发现保罗要投票给特朗普的？
He just mentioned it. He was working at the lawn mower at the time, leaning over it. And he just said something about Sleepy Joe. He wouldn't vote for Sleepy Joe.
他自己提到了。他当时正在修理割草机，俯身在那儿。他只是随口提了一句“瞌睡乔”。他不会投票给“瞌睡乔”。
He wanted to say something back, but told me he didn't think it was worth ruining his relationship with Paul over Trump. There is a stereotypical thing that happens in the Midwest, an aversion to direct conflict. People are so completely loud and aggressive with their signs. For example, down the road from my grandpa's house, there's a huge "Trump, fuck your feelings" sign posted in a neighbor's yard. But to each other's faces, everyone keeps it polite. They let their signs do the talking.
他想反驳，但告诉我，他不认为因为特朗普而毁掉他和保罗的关系是值得的。在中西部有一种陈腐的现象，就是对直接冲突的回避。人们在展示牌子时完全喧闹且具有攻击性。例如，顺着我爷爷家那条路走下去，邻居院子里立着一块巨大的“特朗普，去你的感情”的牌子。但在面对面时，每个人都保持礼貌。他们让牌子替他们说话。
I have a theory about why he's going through this very late in life political awakening. He's been able to vote in 18 presidential elections. But this is the first time he's actually been engaged. Part of it is that as he's gotten older, he hasn't been able to do as much around the farm. He still rides around on his four-wheeler and fixes fences, but he's also started spending more time in front of the TV. He watches The View in the morning and Stephen Colbert at night. He also just finished reading a couple books on the Trumps.
关于他为什么在晚年经历这次政治觉醒，我有一个理论。他已经能够参加18次总统选举投票了。但这是他第一次真正参与。部分原因是随着年龄增长，他没法在农场做那么多事了。他仍然骑着四轮车四处巡视，修理围栏，但他开始花更多时间在电视机前。他早上看《观点》，晚上看斯蒂芬·科尔伯特的节目。他还刚读完几本关于特朗普的书。
Two of my grandpa's daughters, my mom and my Aunt Margaret, have probably influenced him the most. They're at his house a lot, checking on him, playing cards, and dropping off meals. Over the years, their politics have changed. They went from voting for both Bushes to Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton. And this year-- Biden.
我爷爷的两个女儿，我妈和我玛格丽特阿姨，可能对他影响最大。她们经常去他家，看望他，打牌，送餐。多年来，她们的政治观点也变了。她们从投票给两位布什总统转为投票给贝拉克·奥巴马和希拉里·克林顿。今年……拜登。
How long did it take you to figure out that Trump was not that change that you wanted?
你花了多久才弄明白特朗普不是你想要的那个改变？
Well, this virus has really convinced me because he totally disregarded it and still does. He acts as if it don't exist. And all these people are dying, and he still thinks that's all you have to do, is just ignore it. And then he said, it'll be over with by Easter. It'll be over with by July. And it's always a bunch of damn lies. It scares the hell out of me. I ain't ready to die yet.
嗯，这个病毒真正说服了我，因为他完全无视它，现在依然如此。他表现得好像它不存在一样。而所有这些人都死了，他还认为你唯一要做的就是忽略它。然后他说，复活节前就会结束。七月份就会结束。这总是一堆该死的谎言。这吓坏了我。我还不想死。
And then the deal the way they were handling those children down at the border, herding them around like a prisoner of war camp. 500-some are separated from their parents, and some of them are six months old.
还有他们对待边境那些孩子的方式，像对待战俘营一样把他们赶来赶去。500多个孩子与父母分离，有些甚至才六个月大。
It sounds like thinking about those kids without their parents has really stuck with you.
听起来想到那些没有父母的孩子，真的让你耿耿于怀。
Well, why wouldn't it? With anybody, anybody with feeling. Trump has no feeling. Absolutely none. That's why I like Joe Biden, because he has a soft voice and he doesn't tell lies. I wanted someone who cares for someone or something besides himself.
嗯，为什么不会呢？任何人，任何有感情的人都会这样。特朗普没有感情。绝对没有。这就是我喜欢乔·拜登的原因，因为他嗓音柔和，从不撒谎。我想要一个关心除了自己以外的人或事的人。
Would you have thought I was crazy if, in 2016, I told you, hey, you would vote for a Democrat in 2020, straight down the ticket?
如果我在2016年告诉你，嘿，你会投票给民主党，全票投给民主党，你会觉得我疯了吗？
If you would have told me what was going on now back then, I wouldn't have believed this could happen.
如果你当时告诉我现在发生的事情，我不会相信这会发生。
Has been so vocal about supporting Biden hurt any of your relationships with family? Because I know that not everyone in our family is Democratic.
如此高调支持拜登，是否伤害了你与家人的关系？因为我知道家里不是每个人都是民主党。
Oh, Kathy and Kirk in town.
哦，镇上的凯西和柯克。
Kathy's my aunt, and Kirk's her husband. They're Republican.
凯西是我姨妈，柯克是她丈夫。他们是共和党人。
She was bringing my groceries out so that I didn't have to get out and expose myself. And somewhere along the line, I asked her point blank. I said, are you wearing a mask? And she said no. They're no good. They don't do you any good. You can get sick wearing them anyway. And I said, well, I will get my groceries myself after this. And she said, we can still bring the groceries out in the refrigerator. And I said, you won't come on the place-- on the farm without a mask. And she hung up, and I haven't heard from her since.
她当时把买的杂货送过来，这样我就不必出去暴露自己。谈话间，我直截了当地问她。我说，你戴口罩了吗？她说没有。口罩没用。它们对你没好处。反正戴着也会生病。我说，那以后我自己去买杂货。她说，我们可以把杂货放在冰箱里。我说，没口罩你不能进农场。她挂了电话，从那以后我就没再听过她的消息。
My grandpa was ecstatic when he heard the news that Biden won. Some of his neighbors have already taken down their Trump signs. But he has no plans to take his Biden-Harris sign down anytime soon. He wants to make sure all of his neighbors know he was on the winning side. He can see it from his living room window. And he checks on it often to make sure nobody has vandalized it or stolen it. He told me is going to decorate it with flowers and horseshoes and then keep it up, blaring there in his field until a new crop goes in next spring.
当我爷爷听说拜登获胜的消息时，他欣喜若狂。他的一些邻居已经撤下了特朗普的牌子。但他完全没有打算撤下他的拜登-哈里斯牌子。他想确保所有的邻居都知道他站在胜出的一方。从客厅窗户就能看到它。他经常去检查，确保没人毁坏或偷走它。他告诉我，他打算用花和马蹄铁装饰它，然后把它一直留在那里，在他的田地里闪耀，直到明年春天播种新作物。
Lizzie Johnson, she's a reporter for The San Francisco Chronicle.
莉齐·约翰逊，她是《旧金山纪事报》的一名记者。
Act Two, Puppy Love Triangle. So next, we have a story about somebody very young trying to make up her mind about something about as far from politics as we could think of-- a crush on a boy. The way she went about it, though, surprised her mom a lot. The story actually starts back when school was in session last year, pre-virus, in-person school-- remember that? The little girl was in the second grade. Her mom, Emily Flake, explains.
第二幕，青梅竹马的三角恋。接下来是一个关于某个非常年轻的人试图下定决心处理一些事的故事，这与政治相去甚远——对一个男孩的迷恋。不过她处理这件事的方式，让她的妈妈感到非常惊讶。这个故事实际上始于去年还在上学的时候，那是疫情前，线下课堂——还记得吗？那个小女孩在读二年级。她的妈妈，艾米丽·弗莱克，解释道。
To understand why it was so surprising for me to find my seven-year-old in a state of romantic equivocation, I have to explain a bit of her relationship history first. Augustine-- we call her Tug for short-- fell in love for the first time at the age of four. She fell hard for a boy her age I'll call R to protect his identity. R was absurdly tall for his age. He had long, flaxen hair and looked like a tiny Norse god. Tug used to chase him around the basement of the church where we had a playgroup, announcing, "R! You're going to marry me, R! Right now!"
要理解为什么我发现我七岁的女儿陷入浪漫的犹豫不决如此令人惊讶，我得先解释一下她的恋爱史。奥古斯丁——我们简称她为塔格——在四岁时第一次恋爱了。她深深爱上了一个和她同龄的男孩，为了保护他的隐私，我叫他R。R在他的年纪里高得离谱。他有一头亚麻色的长发，看起来像个小北欧神。塔格过去常在礼拜堂的地下室追着他跑，那是我们聚会的地方，她宣布：“R！你要娶我，R！就在现在！”
Now my husband and I were never the type to use words like "boyfriend" and "girlfriend" about little kids. The framing of children's friendships as romantic that I remember from when I was a child in the '80s feels creepy now. But we try to respect that those feelings are very real to her.
我和我丈夫从来不是那种会对小孩子使用“男朋友”、“女朋友”这类词的人。我记得我在80年代还是孩子时，把儿童友谊框架化为浪漫的那种做法，现在感觉很阴森。但我们尽量尊重那些感受对她来说非常真实。
Tug was all R all the time, all through pre-K and kindergarten. Her pre-K teacher remarked often that she had to remind them to play with other kids, instead of remaining in their tight, little two-person club. But then, in first grade, completely out of the blue, her ardor shifted. All of a sudden, she was talking about some new boy. This boy, who we'll call B, lived catty-corner from us. He was a sweet-faced first-grader who looked a bit like a Cabbage Patch doll. I was shocked by this fickle change of heart so I asked her what happened. She said, evenly, "I am no longer interested in R."
在学前班和幼儿园，塔格一直都是R。她的学前班老师经常提到，她不得不提醒他们去和其他孩子玩，而不是一直待在他们紧密的小两人俱乐部里。但到了小学一年级，完全出人意料的是，她的热情转移了。突然间，她在谈论一个新男孩。这个男孩，我们叫他B，住在我们斜对面。他是一个脸蛋甜美的一年级生，看起来有点像“卷心菜娃娃”。我被这种反复无常的变化惊呆了，所以我问她发生了什么。她平静地说：“我不再对R感兴趣了。”
I'd given Tug a journal to write her feelings in, and B showed up in there. In fact, she produced several reams of B content. She wrote a poem about him that included lines like, "I love your hair, as brown as a bear." She stayed full steam ahead on the B train until this past Valentine's Day, when something happens that surprised and confused us both. For the first time in her life, my daughter didn't know where her heart wanted to go.
我给了塔格一本日志来写下她的感受，B出现在了里面。事实上，她写了好几本关于B的内容。她为他写了一首诗，其中包含了这样的台词：“我爱你棕色如熊的头发。”她在B这条船上一直全速前进，直到今年情人节，发生了一件让我们俩都惊讶和困惑的事。她生命中第一次，我女儿不知道她的心想去往何处。
The chaos factor was this. This year, a boy liked her first. This boy, who we'll call L, made his feelings toward Tug known with a note. We talked about it sitting on the floor in her room one afternoon.
混乱因素是这样的。今年，有个男孩先喜欢上了她。这个男孩，我们叫他L，通过一张纸条表达了他对塔格的感情。一天下午，我们坐在她房间的地板上谈论了这件事。
So it was on Valentine's Day. And actually, he left a note at my table, but it was made out of a Post-It. So the first time, I thought it was just garbage. But then I opened it. And in it was "A plus L," and I think with a heart. And then, I was like, "Does that mean that you wanted to be my Valentine?" And he's like, "Maybe." I'm like, "Sure." And then, he runs up to his friend, and he's like, "She said yes! She said yes!"
是在情人节那天。实际上，他在我的桌子上留了一张纸条，但它是写在便利贴上的。所以第一次，我以为那只是垃圾。但后来我打开了它。里面写着“A 加 L”，我想还有一个爱心。然后，我就想，“那意味着你想成为我的情人吗？”他说，“也许吧。”我说，“当然。”然后，他跑向他的朋友，说：“她说好！她说好！”
Being the pursued instead of the pursuer seemed to throw Tug for a loop. When she talked about it, she seemed fretful and confused and a little embarrassed. She told me at bedtime several nights in a row that she didn't know what to do.
成为被追求者而不是追求者似乎让塔格陷入了困境。当她谈到这件事时，她看起来忧心忡忡、困惑且有点尴尬。她连续几个晚上在睡觉前告诉我，她不知道该怎么办。
Before L gave you the note, what did you think of him?
在L给你那张纸条之前，你怎么看他？
I mostly thought of him as like a friend that I've had since pre-K. But I didn't think of him that much.
我主要觉得他就像个从学前班就认识的朋友。但我对他没想那么多。
So you knew him, but you didn't think of him liking you before?
所以你认识他，但之前没想过他会喜欢你？
No, not really.
没有，没怎么想过。
OK.
哦。
When he wrote that note, I started paying more attention to him, kind of, and started to-- thought about him more.
当他写下那张纸条后，我开始更多地关注他，有点，并开始……更多地想到他。
So if L had never given you a Valentine note, do you think you would have gotten a crush on him or liked him?
如果L从没给过你情人节纸条，你觉得你会迷恋他或喜欢他吗？
Probably not because the note kind of made everything just happen.
大概不会，因为那张纸条让一切自然而然地发生了。
She hid her face in the blankets a lot as we talked. She said now that he brought it up, she guessed she could like him? As the days went on, when I checked on her journal, I saw she'd gone full scorched earth on her past. She'd gone back to the pages about B in her diary and edited them mercilessly. Next to "I love B so much," she wrote "Not anymore."
当我们谈话时，她经常把脸藏在毯子里。她说，既然他提出来了，她猜她可以喜欢他？随着日子一天天过去，当我查看她的日志时，我看到她对过去进行了彻底的清算。她翻回了日记里关于B的页面，无情地编辑它们。在“我非常爱B”旁边，她写下了“不再是了”。
Next to every heart she'd drawn, she wrote the word "no." It was like she was trying to edit her emotions by editing the evidence of them. I tried to explain that she didn't have to erase the past or all the things she wrote and drew to make room for this person in her emotional space. She disregarded my note and went right on striking through.
在她画的每一个心形旁边，她写下了“不”这个词。就好像她试图通过编辑证据来编辑她的情绪。我试图解释说，她不必为了在这个人的情感空间里腾出位置，就抹去过去或她写下和画出的所有东西。她无视了我的笔记，继续划掉。
Can you tell me why you felt like you wanted to do that?
你能告诉我为什么你觉得你想那么做吗？
I don't really know exactly why. I just did it.
我不太清楚具体原因。我只是那么做了。
So did you feel like you couldn't like B anymore because L liked you?
那么你觉得因为L喜欢你，你就不能再喜欢B了吗？
I don't really know.
我真的不知道。
And do you feel like you needed to like L back because he liked you?
而且你觉得因为L喜欢你，你就必须回应他的感情吗？
Again, I still don't really know. Do I have to explain how love works?
同样，我还是不知道。我得解释爱是怎么工作的吗？
Of course my daughter can't explain how love works, and neither can I. I wanted to talk to her more about this to make sure that her burgeoning feelings for L and abandonment of feelings for B were coming from her own will. But when I wanted to talk to her about her emotions, she kept deflecting to his.
当然，我女儿没法解释爱是怎么运作的，我也不能。我想和她多谈谈这件事，以确保她对L萌生的感情和对B的放弃是出自她自己的意愿。但当我想和她谈论她的情绪时，她总是推诿到对方的感受上。
I don't really know what he felt. But I know that he probably felt excited.
我真的不知道他感受到了什么。但我知道他可能感到很兴奋。
Well, how did you feel?
那你感觉如何？
I don't really remember. And I felt really happy for him because he seemed like he was super excited.
我不太记得了。而且我为他感到非常高兴，因为他看起来非常兴奋。
Hearing her express this sense of romantic obligation felt like somebody had copy-pasted my entire adolescence onto my second-grader. I knew that feeling very, very well. I was an unlovely and unlikable child. By the time I was in sixth grade, I had completely assimilated the idea that I was not allowed to turn down affection from anyone if it ever happened to come my way.
听到她表达这种浪漫义务感，感觉就像有人把我整个青春期的经历复制粘贴到了我二年级的女儿身上。我很清楚那种感觉。我是一个不可爱且不受喜欢的孩子。到了六年级，我就完全内化了一个想法：如果有一天有人表现出好感，我绝不允许拒绝。
I remembered being liked by a moody boy when I was 12 and going out on what passed for a double date with him and our respective best friends. We all went for ice cream at the decaying strip mall in town. My friend and I tried to make conversation, while the boy who liked me glowered and muttered under his breath, while the boy who liked my friend got chocolate ice cream all over his face.
我记得12岁时被一个喜怒无常的男孩喜欢，还和他以及我们各自最好的朋友进行了一次所谓的双人约会。我们都去城里破旧的商业街吃冰淇淋。我和朋友试图找话题，而喜欢我的男孩则瞪着眼小声嘟囔，喜欢我朋友的男孩则把巧克力冰淇淋弄得满脸都是。
It was an awkward disaster, but it was also my first official date. The boy's affections made me feel shame and an exciting threat of degradation. But what was I going to do, turn him down? I knew I was looking down the barrel of a lifetime of making the best of things as far as dating was concerned.
那是一场尴尬的灾难，但那也是我的第一次正式约会。那个男孩的好感让我感到羞耻，还有一种令人兴奋的堕落感。但我能怎么办，拒绝他吗？我知道在约会方面，我正面对着一辈子都要凑合过日子的未来。
I thought I had avoided constructing a landscape that would encourage those kinds of feelings to grow in my daughter. Had I somehow already infected her with this idea that she'd better find a way to accept anyone that would have her? As Tug sorted through her feelings, she turned once more to writing, crafting a note she planned to give to L at school.
我原以为我避免了构建一个会鼓励那种感觉在我女儿心中生长的环境。我是否已经在不知不觉中感染了她这个想法，即她最好找到一种方法去接受任何愿意接受她的人？当塔格梳理她的感受时，她又一次转而写字，精心制作了一张她打算在学校给L的纸条。
So can we talk about the note that you wrote him? What did it say?
那我们能谈谈你写给他的纸条吗？上面说了什么？
Dear L-- [GIGGLES] I was thrilled when you asked me to be your Valentine. I just want to say you are kind and-- you are so kind and sweet and nice. And you are a great person.
亲爱的L——[咯咯笑] 你邀请我做你的情人时，我非常激动。我只想说你很善良，而且……你真的很善良、甜美、友好。你是个很棒的人。
I was going to put cute, but I forgot.
我本来想写可爱的，但我忘了。
I couldn't tell if she was genuinely seeing L through new eyes or if she was bending her emotions to fit the situation. But I was interested to see where she was going with this. She held onto the note for a few days, going back and forth, and decided at last to seal the deal and deliver the note to him in school. But she never got the chance. This was last March. While she dithered, the pandemic spread. And by the time she'd made up her mind, her school closed. Her decision was rendered moot.
我不知道她是否真的用全新的视角看待L，还是为了适应情况而扭曲了自己的情感。但我很有兴趣看她想怎么做。她保留了那张纸条好几天，犹豫不决，最终决定达成共识并在学校把纸条交给他。但她没机会了。那是去年三月。在她犹豫期间，疫情蔓延了。到她下定决心时，学校关闭了。她的决定变得毫无意义。
For a few weeks, she talked about him at bedtime. But to a kid her age, out of sight is out of mind. Now her obsession lies where she conducts most of her social life-- Roblox and other online platforms. In a world where there are fly-ride albino bats, there doesn't seem to be a lot of room for crushes. Like so many other things in our lives now, her heart will have to live in limbo.
有几周，她睡觉前会谈论他。但对她这个年纪的孩子来说，眼不见心不烦。现在她的痴迷所在是她大部分社交生活开展的地方——Roblox和其他在线平台。在一个有飞天白化蝙蝠的世界里，似乎没多少空间留给迷恋。就像我们生活中现在发生的其他许多事情一样，她的心将不得不活在悬念中。
Emily Flake, she's a writer and cartoonist for The New Yorker. Coming up, can a macho TV talk show host on daytime TV in Argentina really, really become a feminist? That is in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
艾米丽·弗莱克，她是《纽约客》的作家和漫画家。接下来，阿根廷日间电视节目中一个大男子主义的主持人真的能彻底变成女权主义者吗？那将在芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续播出后一分钟内揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, Personal Recount. In this tense and exhausted post-election moment, we thought it would be refreshing to have stories of that very rare thing, that very hopeful thing-- human beings actually changing their minds. We've arrived at act three of our program. Act Three, The All Too Real Housewives of Argentina.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《个人叙事》。在这个紧张且疲惫的后选举时刻，我们认为分享那种极其罕见、充满希望的事情——人类真正改变主意的故事——会让人耳目一新。我们进入了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《阿根廷非常真实的家庭主妇》。
So this is a story about people changing their attitude about the world in a very significant way. And they're doing it in a setting where you really don't see that kind of thing very often-- daytime television. Jasmine Garsd grew up in Argentina and has this story about daytime TV there. We first broadcast this story a couple years ago.
这是一个关于人们以非常显著的方式改变对世界看法的故事。他们是在一个你真的很少见到这种情况的场景中做到的——日间电视节目。贾斯敏·加尔斯德在阿根廷长大，有一个关于那里日间电视节目的故事。我们几年前首次播出了这个故事。
I watched a lot of television when I was a kid. My grandmother, Iaia, would pick me up at school and bring me back to her place. Her apartment was dark and humid. It smelled like French bread and the exhaust from the buses on the avenue down below. My grandfather was never around.
我小时候看了很多电视。我祖母，Iaia，过去常接我放学，带我回她住的地方。她的公寓阴暗潮湿。闻起来有法棍面包味，还有下面大道上公交车的废气味。我祖父从不在家。
Iaia would make tea, and then we would go to her bedroom and turn the TV on. And suddenly, colors, sound, and sex would pour into the world. It was the early afternoon. It was time for the talk shows.
Iaia会泡茶，然后我们去她的卧室打开电视。突然间，色彩、声音和性涌入世界。那是午后时分。是谈话节目时间。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Argentine talk shows are extreme, even for Latin American television. The women are pumped up with silicone and Botox and sometimes show up wearing almost nothing. The conversation is not just double entendres, but straight up entendres, full-on vulgar language. When I was growing up, it was a parade of pasties, stilettos, feather boas.
阿根廷的谈话节目非常极端，即使在拉美电视中也是如此。女嘉宾们注射了硅胶和肉毒杆菌，有时出现时几乎没穿衣服。对话不仅是双关语，而是直接的下流话，充满庸俗的语言。我长大时，那是一场胸贴、细高跟鞋、羽毛围巾的游行。
One of the most popular shows back then was hosted by a guy named Jorge Rial. He's still on TV. He's kind of the Argentine everyman-- charming and a little bit of a hustler. These days, his TV show is called Intrusos, or Intruders. It takes place on a set that is just seizure inducing-- neon colors, walls lined with giant video screens. Jorge Rial likes to stir up fights among his voluptuous guests. Every time something shocking is said, ominous music rolls out.
那时最受欢迎的节目之一是由一个叫豪尔赫·里亚尔的人主持的。他现在还在电视上。他算是阿根廷的普通人代表——有魅力，还有点精明。这些天，他的电视节目叫《Intrusos》，或《入侵者》。它在一个让人癫狂的摄影棚里拍摄——霓虹色，墙上排列着巨大的视频屏幕。豪尔赫·里亚尔喜欢在那些性感的客人中间挑起争斗。每当有什么令人震惊的话被说出，邪恶的音乐就会响起。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
[OMINOUS MUSIC]
[邪恶的音乐]
Once in a while, a woman is so sexy that Jorge Rial bites his lower lip and mugs for the camera. This has been Rial's style for years. Back in the day, Iaia would bring the tea and cookies and lie down next to me in her patent leather platform shoes, which she never took off, not even in bed.
偶尔，有个女人太性感，豪尔赫·里亚尔会咬下嘴唇，对着镜头做鬼脸。这就是里亚尔多年来的风格。过去，Iaia会拿来茶和饼干，穿着她漆皮松糕鞋躺在我身边，她从不脱下它们，连睡觉时也不。
My grandmother was the target audience for Rial's show, what's commonly known as a [SPANISH], a housewife. She loved to hate the show, to look disapprovingly at the women and comment how much surgery she's had. [SPANISH], a prostitute. [SPANISH]. And they give her expensive gifts-- cars, vacations. And I'd look around me at my grandmother's lonely apartment and think to myself, wow, that sounds pretty amazing. I knew I didn't want to be a [SPANISH] when I grew up.
我祖母是里亚尔节目的目标观众，通常被称为“Dona Rosa”，一位家庭主妇。她喜欢讨厌这个节目，轻蔑地看着那些女人，评论她们做了多少手术。“Prostituta”，妓女。“Gato”。她们给豪尔赫昂贵的礼物——汽车、度假。而我环顾祖母空荡荡的公寓，心想，哇，那听起来很棒。我知道我长大后不想成为“Gato”。
When I was a teenager, I moved to the US and eventually became a journalist. I've lived here for 15 years. Sometimes when I get homesick, I stream Intrusos on YouTube. I leave it on when I cook and clean. When I watch it, I'm not 5,000 miles away. Iaia is alive. Nothing has changed much. Nothing ever changes on Argentine daytime TV. Until suddenly, a few months ago, it did.
十几岁时，我搬到了美国，最终成为了一名记者。我在这里住了15年。有时我想家时，我会在YouTube上流媒体播放《Intrusos》。我做饭和打扫时会开着它。当我看它时，我并不在5000英里之外。Iaia还活着。没什么变化。阿根廷日间电视节目什么都不会变。直到几个月前，它突然变了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
One night in February, I was at home in New York cleaning my kitchen. Intrusos was on in the background, and I heard this woman with a raspy Lauren Bacall voice. I turned around, soapy sponge in hand, and squinted at the screen-- a tattooed, heavyset woman wearing sneakers.
二月的一个晚上，我在纽约家中清理厨房。背景里开着《Intrusos》，我听到一个有着沙哑的劳伦·白考尔嗓音的女人说话。我转过身，手里拿着肥皂海绵，眯着眼看屏幕——一个纹身、身材魁梧的女人穿着运动鞋。
I recognized this woman, a comedian named Senorita Bimbo. The stage name, Bimbo, is ironic. She's anything but. In fact, the very next thing she did was look directly into the camera and offer a statistic about illegal abortion.
我认出了这个女人，一位名叫“Senorita Bimbo”的喜剧演员。艺名“Bimbo”是讽刺性的。她一点也不是笨蛋。事实上，她做的下一件事就是直视镜头，提供了一个关于非法堕胎的统计数据。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
"500,000 women in Argentina have illegal abortions every year," she said. She was wearing a bright green handkerchief around her neck, a provocative symbol everyone in Argentina knows, a symbol of the fight to legalize abortion. For years, activists have been pushing to get Congress to vote on it. When I was growing up, abortion was something you just didn't talk about in Argentina, a Catholic country. It's still not something that comes up on daytime TV. Reproductive rights? That's just not Intrusos source material, though here was Jorge Rial, the host, looking intently at Senorita Bimbo.
她说：“阿根廷每年有50万名女性进行非法堕胎。”她脖子上围着一条鲜艳的绿手帕，这是阿根廷每个人都知道的挑衅性符号，是争取堕胎合法化斗争的象征。多年来，活动人士一直在推动国会投票表决。我长大时，堕胎是阿根廷这个天主教国家里人们根本不谈论的事。它仍然不是日间电视节目里会出现的话题。生育权？那根本不是《Intrusos》的素材，尽管豪尔赫·里亚尔，主持人，正凝视着“Senorita Bimbo”。
A few hours later, one of my best friends texted me, "Did you watch Intrusos today?" I sat down at my laptop and started scrolling through the descriptions of the last few episodes. The guests were names I knew-- academics, writers, comedians. What they had in common was they were all feminists, people who have been on the fringes for years criticizing sexism in Argentina and demanding women's rights.
几小时后，我最好的朋友之一给我发短信：“你今天看《Intrusos》了吗？”我坐在笔记本电脑前，开始浏览过去几集的描述。嘉宾是我熟悉的名字——学者、作家、喜剧演员。他们的共同点是他们都是女权主义者，多年来一直处于边缘，批评阿根廷的性别歧视并要求妇女权利。
I started binge watching. In each episode, there was a nuanced conversation about feminism. Rial looked kind of meek, but not in his usual, I've been overpowered by sexy ladies, way. He kept delivering these really impassioned monologues, saying I don't want to be a misogynist, a [SPANISH]. I'm a recovering [SPANISH].
我开始疯狂观看。每一集中，都有关于女权主义的深入对话。里亚尔看起来有点温顺，但不是那种他通常被性感女士压制的样子。他不断发表这些非常热情的独白，说我不想成为厌女症，一个“Machista”。我是正在康复的“Machista”。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The Argentine everyman now appeared to be an earnest feminist. This was not the Rial I grew up with. This was not the TV I grew up with. What happened? Could this possibly be sincere? I flew to Argentina to find out.
那个阿根廷普通人现在看起来像是个真诚的女权主义者。这不是我从小认识的里亚尔。这不是我从小看的电视。发生了什么？这可能真诚吗？我飞往阿根廷一探究竟。
As soon as I got there, I went to the studios where Intrusos is taped. I met Ana Laura Guevara, one of the show's executive producers.
一到那里，我就去了《Intrusos》的录制影棚。我见到了节目的执行制片人之一，安娜·劳拉·格瓦拉。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Being live involves a lot of adrenaline. I really, really love the adrenaline there.
现场直播涉及很多肾上腺素。我真的、真的非常喜欢那里的肾上腺素。
To be honest, I wasn't expecting an Intrusos executive producer to be a woman, especially not one like Ana Laura, a self-proclaimed feminist. I had a really hard time wrapping my head around the fact that for 18 years, she had been behind this totally trashy and objectifying show. Ana Laura told me, it's just the job, one she's good at. It's intensely competitive.
说实话，我没料到《Intrusos》的执行制片人会是个女性，更没想到会是安娜·劳拉这种自称女权主义者的人。我真的很难接受这样一个事实：18年来，她一直在这档完全垃圾且物化女性的节目背后。安娜·劳拉告诉我，这只是工作，她擅长这份工作。它竞争激烈。
In the control room, her face shines from the light of the monitor she's hunched over, like in a casino. A monitor that, minute by minute, tracks the ratings for Intrusos and every other show that's on the air at the same time. I had no idea this was possible. Right now on Intrusos, there's a fight between a former cabaret dancer and a potential candidate for president.
在控制室里，她的脸被她弓着身子盯着的监视器照得发亮，就像在赌场一样。一个逐分钟追踪《Intrusos》和同时段播出所有其他节目收视率的监视器。我不知道这居然可能。现在《Intrusos》上，有一位前歌舞表演舞者和一位总统候选人之间的争吵。
This skyrocketed. The ratings are going up with this segment. It went from 4.0 to 4.6. This is doing better than the news.
这飙升了。收视率随着这个环节上升。从4.0到了4.6。这比新闻节目表现更好。
Next segment, a fashion model from the '80s says she has her suspicions about a designer's recent death.
下一个环节，一位80年代的时装模特说她对一位设计师最近的去世表示怀疑。
It dipped to 3.4.
收视率跌到了3.4。
The ratings plummet, nobody cares. Ana Laura orders them to end the segment early. Interest lags for an instant, and Intrusos moves on.
收视率暴跌，没人关心。安娜·劳拉命令他们提前结束环节。兴趣一旦消退，节目就会继续。
The story of how the feminists intruded into Intrusos is its own soap opera. There are a gazillion gossip shows in Argentina. It's like this whole universe. Back in January, one of the shows interviewed this famous singer, a leathery guy in a tropical shirt. In the middle of the interview, the singer casually repeats this awful saying I used to hear as a kid. "If someone wants to rape you, relax and enjoy it."
女权主义者如何“侵入”《Intrusos》的故事本身就是一出肥皂剧。阿根廷有数不清的八卦节目。这就像一个完整的宇宙。一月时，其中一个节目采访了这位著名歌手，一个穿着热带衬衫、皮肤粗糙的家伙。采访中，歌手随口重复了我小时候常听到的那句糟糕的话。“如果有人想强奸你，放松并享受它。”
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The first time I heard that was when I was nine years old. I was in the locker room, and a girl blurted it out. I thought it was advice. A lot of my friends did, too. So the singer says this offensive thing. A few days later, on another talk show, a soap opera star blows up about it. Her name is Araceli Gonzalez. When I was a kid, her soap opera was huge. She played a mute. A hunk with feathered hair would talk at her while she listened tearfully. But now she wasn't mute. She said the singer's remark made her sick.
我第一次听到那话时才九岁。我在更衣室里，一个女孩脱口而出。我以为那是建议。我的很多朋友也这么认为。所以歌手说了那句冒犯的话。几天后，在另一个谈话节目上，一位肥皂剧明星对它爆发了。她叫阿拉塞利·冈萨雷斯。我小时候，她的肥皂剧非常红。她演过一个哑巴。一个留着羽毛发型的帅哥会在她听着流泪时对她说话。但现在她不哑了。她说歌手的言论让她感到恶心。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
It was kind of beautiful seeing her get angry after so many years of playing a character literally defined by silence. Ana Laura from Intrusos saw the fight happening on TV, and she wanted to get a piece of it. She booked Araceli to come on the show.
看到她在这个多年来扮演完全由沉默定义角色的角色后感到愤怒，真是有点美妙。《Intrusos》的安娜·劳拉看到了电视上发生的这场争斗，她想分一杯羹。她预约了阿拉塞利来节目。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
It was a typical day on Intrusos. Jorge Rial talked about how much granny panties used to turn him on as a kid. Two former showgirls argued. And then it was Araceli's turn. And just because Araceli had gotten mad about the rape comment, one of the panelists introduces her as a feminist. As soon as Araceli got a chance, she corrected him.
这是《Intrusos》典型的一天。豪尔赫·里亚尔谈论着他小时候奶奶内裤有多让他兴奋。两位前秀场女郎争论不休。然后轮到阿拉塞利了。就因为阿拉塞利对强奸评论感到生气，其中一位小组成员把她介绍为女权主义者。阿拉塞利一有机会就纠正了他。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
She says, "I heard you refer to me as a feminist just now, and I am not a feminist." She's vehemently wagging her finger as she says this.
她说：“我刚才听到你把我称为女权主义者，但我不是女权主义者。”她说话时愤慨地摇晃着手指。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
"I have a wonderful husband and a lovely son whom I love very much, and I respect men." This set off another firestorm. Here's Ana Laura.
“我有一个很棒的丈夫和一个我非常爱的可爱的儿子，我尊重男人。”这引发了另一场风暴。这是安娜·劳拉。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So people started tweeting about it and we saw that feminists started to respond.
所以人们开始在推特上讨论它，我们看到女权主义者开始回应。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So everything exploded.
所以一切都爆发了。
There were the kinds of tweets you would expect like, quote, "What the fuck does loving your husband and son have to do with being a feminist, you moron?" And here it was, feminist versus the soap opera star, a fight made for daytime television. And Ana Laura knew it. And she also knew Jorge Rial, the host of the show, something had been changing with him lately. He'd been saying to anyone who would listen--
出现了你们会预料到的推文，比如：“你这个白痴，热爱丈夫和儿子跟成为女权主义者有什么鬼关系？”这就是女权主义者对阵肥皂剧明星，一场为日间电视节目打造的争斗。安娜·劳拉知道这一点。她也知道豪尔赫·里亚尔，节目主持人，最近他身上发生了一些变化。他一直对任何愿意听的人说……
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I am a [SPANISH] in recovery. I'm trying to find myself.
我是正在康复的“Machista”。我在努力寻找自我。
So she approached him in the dressing room. And they started talking. Maybe we should have a feminist on the show to explain what feminism is.
所以她在更衣室里接近了他。他们开始交谈。也许我们应该请一位女权主义者上节目，解释什么是女权主义。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
We hadn't discussed that beforehand, but this day, in the dressing room, I think that he was really into it.
我们之前没讨论过，但那天，在更衣室里，我觉得他真的很投入。
They decided on a well-known feminist academic, Flor Freijo. And even she'll tell you, she's a safe bet for a show like Intrusos. She's thin and blonde. So Flor gets invited to Intrusos, and the very first question Jorge Rial asks her is, what is feminism?
他们选择了著名的女权主义学者弗洛尔·弗雷霍。甚至她也会告诉你，她对《Intrusos》这样的节目来说是个稳妥的选择。她身材苗条，金发碧眼。所以弗洛尔被邀请到《Intrusos》，豪尔赫·里亚尔问她的第一个问题就是：什么是女权主义？
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I didn't prepare anything. I didn't prepare a speech. I didn't have time. So I went open to listen to the questions and explain things just as I do to my students in a class.
我没准备任何东西。我没准备演讲。我没时间。所以我敞开心扉去听问题，并像我在课堂上对学生解释那样解释事情。
Of all the strange things I've seen on Argentine TV, this might be one of the oddest. Against a neon fizz background, Flor Freijo does a feminism 101. At the bottom of the screen, a banner in bold letters reads, "Feminism-- it's a movement for women's rights." Flor starts explaining, feminism is a movement for women's rights. It started in the 19th century. It has to do with the division of labor, child rearing.
在我看过的所有奇怪的阿根廷电视节目中，这可能是最奇怪的一个之一。在霓虹色背景下，弗洛尔·弗雷霍做了一个“女权主义101”。屏幕底部，一条加粗的横幅写着：“女权主义——这是一场为妇女权利而进行的运动。”弗洛尔开始解释，女权主义是一场为妇女权利而进行的运动。它始于19世纪。它与劳动分工、子女抚养有关。
Jorge Rial is listening, completely mesmerized, his little eyebrows furrowed, scratching his beard. And while all this is happening, Ana Laura is sitting in the control room upstairs, watching everything, of course, and also keeping her eye on the ratings monitor. The control room is usually a chaotic mess of yelling, but now, with Flor speaking--
豪尔赫·里亚尔听着，完全被迷住了，他那细小的眉毛皱着，抓着胡子。而当这一切发生时，安娜·劳拉正坐在楼上的控制室里，当然在观看一切，也盯着收视率监视器。控制室通常是一片混乱的吼叫，但现在，随着弗洛尔讲话……
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And when we were watching her talking, Flor, the control room went quiet. We were all paying attention to what she was saying. But we were all quiet. We weren really silently watching and learning from her.
当我们看着她说话，弗洛尔，控制室安静了下来。我们都在注意听她在说什么。但我们都很安静。我们真的在安静地观看并从她那里学习。
And then the spell is broken because the phone rings in the control room. It's Araceli, the soap opera star, who's the whole reason Flor is here. She wants to talk to Flor live right now. Everyone in the control room is geared up for a good old-fashioned Intrusos spat.
然后咒语被打破了，因为控制室电话响了。是肥皂剧明星阿拉塞利，弗洛尔出现在这里全是她的原因。她现在想在直播中和弗洛尔谈话。控制室里的每个人都准备好迎接一场老式的《Intrusos》争吵了。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Flor was kind of shocked.
弗洛尔感到有点震惊。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I didn't know that Araceli was going to call. I had no idea of what was going to happen.
我不知道阿拉塞利会打电话来。我根本不知道会发生什么。
But it wasn't an ambush. Araceli wasn't calling to fight. Instead, she tells Flor, I've been listening really well to what you're saying, and she wanted the audience to know that she didn't know what feminism was until just now, when she was watching TV and saw Flor explain it.
但那不是伏击。阿拉塞利打电话来不是为了争斗。相反，她告诉弗洛尔，我一直在认真听你在说什么，她想让观众知道，直到刚才看电视看到弗洛尔解释之前，她根本不知道什么是女权主义。
She starts telling the story of her life through various generations of women, her own single mother and herself. She talks about how she'd been sexually abused as a child and emotionally abused as an adult. And Araceli told Flor, "I know what you're talking about, and I agree with you. If this means being a feminist, then I'm a feminist."
她开始通过几代女性的生活讲述她的故事，她自己的单亲母亲和她自己。她谈到她小时候是如何受到性虐待，成年后受到情感虐待的。阿拉塞利告诉弗洛尔：“我知道你在说什么，我同意你的观点。如果这意味着女权主义，那么我就是女权主义者。”
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Flor nods and gives a thumbs up. By the way, this is never how Intrusos finishes. People don't just listen to each other and change their minds. And the ratings, Ana Laura says the ratings were great, strong enough that she decided, let's do this again tomorrow. And so it began.
弗洛尔点了点头并竖起了大拇指。顺便说一句，《Intrusos》从不是这样结束的。人们不会只是倾听对方并改变主意。而收视率，安娜·劳拉说收视率很棒，好到她决定，明天再来一次。于是它开始了。
[OMINOUS MUSIC]
[邪恶的音乐]
Over the next few days, some of the most famous feminists in Argentina came on to Intrusos-- comedians, authors, professors. Audiences were stunned. Someone tweeted, "My ideology is starting to converge with Jorge Rial's, and that terrifies me." It was pretty strange for everyone. This very misogynistic show had suddenly become like the public town hall on feminism in Argentina.
接下来的几天里，阿根廷最著名的一些女权主义者来到了《Intrusos》——喜剧演员、作家、教授。观众们惊呆了。有人发推文说：“我的意识形态开始与豪尔赫·里亚尔的趋同了，这让我感到恐惧。”这对每个人来说都相当奇怪。这个非常厌女的节目突然变成了阿根廷女权主义的公开市政厅。
And the ratings were not just good. Ana Laura says they were higher than normal. She was delighted that she could keep this going.
而且收视率不仅很好。安娜·劳拉说它们比平时更高。她很高兴自己能让这种情况持续下去。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
There is a journalist called Luciana Baker. She is also very important in feminism. And she is an old friend from college. And she came to our show. And when we met backstage, we were like, not even in our wildest dreams we could have dreamed about this, you being here in this type of show.
有一位名叫卢西亚娜·贝克的记者。她在女权主义中也非常重要。她也是我的大学老同学。她来到我们的节目。当我们在后台见面时，我们想，甚至在最疯狂的梦里，我们都无法想象会发生这种事，你出现在这种节目里。
Midway through all of this is when I tuned down, when I started streaming in New York. The show was going through hundreds of years of feminism in a couple of days. They passed through topics like LGBT rights, workplace harassment, income inequality, and then the most taboo thing of all-- abortion.
这一切进展到一半时，我收听了，当我开始在纽约流媒体播放时。节目在几天之内经历了几百年的女权主义。他们讨论了LGBT权利、工作场所骚扰、收入不平等，然后是最禁忌的事情——堕胎。
Jorge Rial tied the green handkerchief around his wrist, the one activists who want to legalize abortion wear. And then he invited the large woman with the gravelly voice who I saw at home in New York City-- Senorita Bimbo. Right off the bat, she said, the fact that there is a fat girl on Argentine TV is already a victory.
豪尔赫·里亚尔把那条绿手帕绑在手腕上，这是那些想要堕胎合法化的活动人士佩戴的颜色。然后他邀请了我回纽约家时看到的那个嗓音沙哑的魁梧女人——“Senorita Bimbo”。她一开口就说，阿根廷电视上出现一个胖女孩本身就是一场胜利。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
She told me she was actually pretty nervous.
她告诉我她实际上很紧张。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The first thing I thought was, what they're all going to say is like, what is this fat girl doing here, this fat girl feminazi?
我脑子里闪过的第一件事是，他们会说的肯定是，这个胖女孩在这里干什么，这个胖女孩女权纳粹？
But she powered through. She had a mission.
但她坚持了下来。她有一个使命。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I knew I wanted to talk about abortion. My plan was to at least mention it. And I just sat down and started talking. I felt like I was going to battle where I had to use words as arrows because abortion is something that you don't see. It's something that you talk about in hushed tones if you have one.
我知道我想谈堕胎。我的计划是至少提一下。我坐下来开始谈话。我觉得我是在去打仗，我得用语言作为箭头，因为堕胎是你看不见的东西。如果你堕胎，你只能在低声耳语中谈论它。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
On Intrusos, Senorita Bimbo talked about how abortion is so taboo, you don't even talk about it in fiction. In Argentine TV and film, unwanted pregnancy is solved by a villain pushing you down the stairs and causing you to miscarry.
在《Intrusos》上，“Senorita Bimbo”谈到了堕胎是多么禁忌，你甚至在小说里都不谈论它。在阿根廷的电视和电影中，未婚先孕总是通过反派把你推下楼梯导致流产来解决。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And then, about 30 seconds before they cut to commercial and moved to the next guest, Senorita Bimbo said something about abortion that surprised even her.
然后，在他们切到广告并转向下一位嘉宾前约30秒，“Senorita Bimbo”说了一些关于堕胎的事情，连她自己都感到惊讶。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Misoprostol. She says, "I want girls to know about misoprostol." This is a really big deal. Officially, misoprostol is a drug used to treat stomach ulcers, but it can also be used to induce labor. So in a continent where abortion is mostly banned, women take it if they want to miscarry. People call it the DIY abortion.
米索前列醇。她说：“我想让女孩们知道米索前列醇。”这可是件大事。官方来说，米索前列醇是一种用于治疗胃溃疡的药物，但它也可以用于引产。因此，在一个大部分禁止堕胎的大陆，女性如果想流产就会服用它。人们称之为“自助式堕胎”。
She's talking about doing something illegal on one of the most popular daytime talk shows, watched by housewives. That same day, misoprostol was one of the most googled words in the country. I think you're underestimating your audience, Senorita Bimbo said on the show. The [SPANISH] is dead. The [SPANISH], that stereotypical Argentine housewife.
她在最受欢迎的日间谈话节目之一中谈论做非法的事情，观众是家庭主妇。就在那天，米索前列醇成为该国谷歌搜索量最高的词之一。我觉得你们低估了你们的观众，“Senorita Bimbo”在节目上说。“Dona Rosa”死了。“Dona Rosa”，那个典型的阿根廷家庭主妇。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
So the woman that is in front of the TV and who needs her world to be explained to her through daytime TV, she just doesn't exist anymore.
所以那个站在电视机前，需要通过日间电视节目向她解释世界的人，她根本就不存在了。
Of course, none of this would have happened on Intrusos if the ratings had been bad. And the ratings were great, for reasons that Jorge Rial and Ana Laura can claim no credit for at all. Feminism has been gaining critical mass in Argentina for the last couple of years.
当然，如果收视率很差，这一切都不会在《Intrusos》上发生。而收视率很棒，这是豪尔赫·里亚尔和安娜·劳拉根本无法邀功的原因。女权主义在过去几年里在阿根廷获得了临界质量。
The movement was triggered by these brutal murders of young women, often by boyfriends, husbands, and fathers. Women started protesting. A whole crusade was born. It was called Ni Una Menos, not one less woman. And since 2015, this has grown to the point where it's impossible to ignore and has expanded to abortion rights, street harassment, and equal pay. It's young people on social media, comedians on YouTube, pop stars on Instagram, gigantic demonstrations. It just wasn't a topic for daytime talk shows until Jorge, Ana Laura, and Intrusos.
这场运动是由年轻女性遭受的残酷谋杀引发的，通常是男友、丈夫和父亲所为。女性开始抗议。一场完整的十字军东征诞生了。它叫“Ni Una Menos”，一个都不能少。自2015年以来，这已经发展到无法被忽视的地步，并扩展到堕胎权、街头骚扰和平等待遇。这是社交媒体上的年轻人、YouTube上的喜剧演员、Instagram上的流行歌星、巨大的示威活动。直到豪尔赫、安娜·劳拉和《Intrusos》，这根本不是日间谈话节目的话题。
During that week on Intrusos, there was this explosion of tweets from young girls, perplexed but ecstatic to see feminism on daytime TV. This one girl, Anita Ocampo, tweeted, "I showed my dad the Intrusos episode with Senorita Bimbo." I dropped by her house, and she told me these feminists were explaining to Jorge Rial all the things she tried to explain, but couldn't get her parents to understand. So one night, she approached her dad.
在那周《Intrusos》节目中，推特上涌现了年轻女孩的爆炸式讨论，她们感到困惑但兴奋地看到日间电视上有女权主义。一个女孩，安妮塔·奥坎波，发推文说：“我给爸爸看了那集有‘Senorita Bimbo’的《Intrusos》。”我顺路去了她家，她告诉我，这些女权主义者在向豪尔赫·里亚尔解释她试图解释但无法让父母理解的所有事情。所以一天晚上，她接近了她的父亲。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And she told him, "If you watch this episode of Intrusos on YouTube with me, I'll massage your feet." She ended up getting the whole family to watch. She showed them Senorita Bimbo. She pointed to Jorge Rial wearing the same green handkerchief she wears and said, "Look, it's just like mine."
她告诉他：“如果你和我一起在YouTube上看这集《Intrusos》，我就给你按摩脚。”她最终让全家都看了。她给他们看了“Senorita Bimbo”。她指着戴着和她一样绿手帕的豪尔赫·里亚尔说：“看，这和我的一样。”
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
It opened up a conversation, which she says they've been having ever since. Anita's mom says she saw Jorge Rial talk about how he's a recovering chauvinist. And she says, so is she.
它打开了一个对话，她说从那以后他们一直都在谈论这个。安妮塔的妈妈说她看到豪尔赫·里亚尔谈论他是如何成为一名正在康复的沙文主义者的。她说，她也是。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
"I'm not like 70% feminism," she says. "I still have 30% left to go."
“我不是70%的女权主义者，”她说。“我还有30%的路要走。”
During my week in Argentina, I kept trying to talk to Jorge Rial, and he kept blowing me off. Had he really converted to feminism? Everyone I asked rolled their eyes and pointed to the last few decades of his career. They pointed to his recent vicious public fight with one of his daughters. They pointed to how late he is to the whole feminism thing. He's a Johnny come lately. He's only doing this because it'll make him more popular.
我在阿根廷那周，一直试图和豪尔赫·里亚尔交谈，他一直对我爱搭不理。他真的皈依女权主义了吗？我问的每个人都翻白眼，指着他过去几十年的职业生涯。他们指着他最近与其中一个女儿恶毒的公开争吵。他们指着他在女权主义这件事上有多晚。他是个迟来的人。他这么做只是因为这会让他更受欢迎。
After days of giving me the runaround, he told me to just send my questions. And finally, on my very last night in Argentina, my phone lit up. It was voice memos from Jorge Rial.
在让我绕了几天圈子后，他告诉我只管发我的问题。终于，在我在阿根廷的最后一晚，我的手机亮了。那是豪尔赫·里亚尔发来的语音备忘录。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
"What happened to me?" Rial says. "What made me bring all these feminists onto Intrusos?"
“我发生了什么事？”里亚尔说。“是什么让我把所有这些女权主义者请上《Intrusos》的？”
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He talks about his 18-year-old daughter, Rosio, and how she's a feminist. "We have these very interesting talks over dinner," he says. "And she started opening this world up to me. I am 56 years old. I was raised in a completely sexist culture. I didn't get it. That's why I say I'm a recovering chauvinist, thanks to my daughter. My daughter made me change."
他谈到了他18岁的女儿罗西奥，以及她是如何成为女权主义者的。“我们在晚餐时谈得很投机，”他说。“她开始为我打开这个世界。我已经56岁了。我是在一个完全性别歧视的文化中长大的。我没明白。这就是为什么我说我是正在康复的沙文主义者，多亏了我的女儿。我的女儿让我改变了。”
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Jorge Rial knows that I think Intrusos is stupid. He knows most people do. That's the show's superpower.
豪尔赫·里亚尔知道我觉得《Intrusos》很愚蠢。他知道大多数人都这么认为。那是节目的超能力。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
"Frivolo--" we're frivolous. We're a show about show biz. No one suspected that this is where feminism could win. We eluded the firewalls that kept feminism off of TV. There was this wall. You couldn't talk about these things on TV. And suddenly it happened on Intrusos. But to be honest, he said, it's all because of feminists. They knew any place is good if you have a strong message.
“Frivolo——”我们很轻浮。我们是一个关于演艺圈的节目。没人想到这居然是女权主义可能获胜的地方。我们避开了让女权主义无法上电视的防火墙。那儿有一堵墙。你不能在电视上谈论这些事情。而它突然在《Intrusos》上发生了。但老实说，他说，这全是因为女权主义者。她们知道只要你有强有力的信息，任何地方都是好地方。
[SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
After the week of feminism, Intrusos was left with a split personality. These days, it's a mix of fighting starlets and women's rights activists. Jorge Rial's social media is a mix of World Cup woes, celebrity gossip, and then these really earnest feminist tweets, like this one a few weeks ago. "They came to make things better for the coming generations for our daughters and their daughters and also for men. The men who come after us must be better than us. We did everything wrong."
那周女权主义节目后，《Intrusos》留下了一个分裂的人格。这些天，它是争吵的小明星和妇女权利活动家们的混合体。豪尔赫·里亚尔的社交媒体是世界杯的苦恼、名人八卦，以及这些非常真诚的女权主义推文的混合体，比如几周前的那一条：“她们来到这里，是为了让未来几代人，为了我们的女儿和她们的女儿，也为了男人变得更好。随后而来的男人必须比我们更好。我们把一切都做错了。”
The day after he tweeted that on June 14th, Argentina's lower house of Congress approved a bill to legalize abortion. After an all night debate, it barely passed by only four votes. And it yet has to pass the upper house. Still, outside Congress, thousands of women and activists who'd gathered to wait for the results celebrated wildly.
在他发布那条推文的第二天，即6月14日，阿根廷众议院通过了一项堕胎合法化的法案。经过整夜的辩论，它以仅四票之差勉强通过。它还有待参议院通过。尽管如此，在国会外，数千名聚集等待结果的女性和活动家疯狂地庆祝。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Every time I spoke to those women about what role television like Intrusos played in all this, they got uncomfortable. On my last day in Argentina, I grabbed a coffee with an old friend from high school, Jordana Timmerman. She recently wrote an op-ed for The New York Times about the push to legalize abortion in Argentina. And we talked about the role pop culture played in that.
每次我和那些女性谈论像《Intrusos》这样的电视节目在这一切中发挥了什么作用时，她们都会感到不安。在阿根廷的最后一天，我和高中老朋友乔达娜·蒂默曼一起喝咖啡。她最近为《纽约时报》写了一篇关于阿根廷推动堕胎合法化的专栏文章。我们谈到了流行文化在其中发挥的作用。
You need to have people like Rial or pop culture, dona rosa, understanding that this is a necessary right because if not, it's not going to happen.
你需要有像里亚尔或者大众文化这样的人，让Dona Rosa理解这是一项必要的权利，因为如果不这样，它就不会发生。
In other words, the message needs to go into homes in the most remote locations of the country. And TV is one of the only ways to do that. Jordana was saying Intrusos helped. But when I asked her about whether we should thank Jorge Rial, she just laughs.
换句话说，信息需要进入该国最偏远地区的家庭。而电视是做到这一点的唯一途径。乔达娜说《Intrusos》有帮助。但当我问她我们是否应该感谢豪尔赫·里亚尔时，她只是笑了。
I'm not going on record with that. Are you crazy? I have a name.
我不会在记录上说那个。你疯了吗？我还有名声呢。
I know what she means. After so many years of awful television and this guy's shenanigans, I just don't want to tip my hat to him. And maybe that's part of his penance. He did something good, and no one will ever thank him for it.
我明白她的意思。在看了这么多年的垃圾电视和这个家伙的诡计之后，我只是不想向他致敬。也许那是他赎罪的一部分。他做了一件好事，永远不会有人感谢他。
Jasmine Garsd. She's a senior reporter at Marketplace. This story was co-produced with Marianne McCune as part of a collaboration with the NPR podcast, Rough Translation, which you can find whenever you get your podcasts.
贾斯敏·加尔斯德。她是Marketplace的一名资深记者。这个故事是与玛丽安·麦库恩共同制作的，是与NPR播客《Rough Translation》合作的一部分，你可以在获取播客的任何地方找到它。
So we first put this story out in 2018. And the changes in Jorge Rial, they didn't exactly stick. Rial's show went back to its original content in the year since. And he recently said he is not a feminist and that, quote, "It was all a mistake, having those feminists on the show." He does still describe himself as a recovering misogynist, however. And as far as the country of Argentina, abortion is still very restricted there. The Senate ended up rejecting the bill mentioned in the story.
我们于2018年首次发布了这个故事。豪尔赫·里亚尔的变化并没有真正持续下去。在他发布故事后的几年里，里亚尔的节目又回到了它原本的内容。他最近说他不是女权主义者，并引用称：“让那些女权主义者上节目，那完全是个错误。”然而，他确实仍然称自己为正在康复的厌女症患者。至于阿根廷这个国家，堕胎在那里仍然受到严格限制。参议院最终否决了故事中提到的法案。
[MUSIC - "I CAN CHANGE" BY LCD SOUNDSYSTEM]
[音乐 - LCD SOUNDSYSTEM演唱的《I CAN CHANGE》]
Our program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Noor Gill, Damian Grave, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德制作。今天节目组成员包括比姆·阿德温米、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔洪、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、努尔·吉尔、达米安·格雷夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、塞思·林德、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Paul Bresnahan, Matt Fuller, Chris Crawford, and Cecil Ranieri.
我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的资深编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。今天特别感谢保罗·布雷斯纳汉、马特·富勒、克里斯·克劳福德和塞西尔·拉涅利。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he just called President Trump, telling him to concede, but not just to concede. Torey gave him some proposed language. He was like, OK, listen. This is what you should say to Joe Biden. Just put it exactly like this.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道吗，他刚给特朗普总统打电话，告诉他要认输，但不仅仅是认输。托里给了他一些提议的语言。他说，好吧，听着。这就是你应该对乔·拜登说的。就这样照着说。
I just want to say you are kind and-- you are so kind, and sweet, and nice. And you are a great person.
我只想说你很善良，而且……你真的很善良、甜美、友好。你是个很棒的人。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "I CAN CHANGE" BY LCD SOUNDSYSTEM]
[音乐 - LCD SOUNDSYSTEM演唱的《I CAN CHANGE》]